All right It is time for Drew's News,
where we get to hang out the news net
and gently snag those beautiful, good news butterflies,
(mimics whooshing) nothing but net.
And with me at the desk is a man as graceful as a butterfly
Rossy Ross Matthews.
That's right.
Hi everybody.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
Oh, Douglas, Douglas is right down here.
I mean, remember when it was you, me and Douglas?
I do remember.
I am so happy he's come for visiting day.
All right, first up, this story is,
it's a mind twister but it's got a lot of depth.
Cole Sprouse, who is the handsome, talented,
beautiful, wonderful actor that we've watched grow up.
In fact, him and his twin brother were in "Big Daddy"
and they became huge Disney stars with their show
the "Suite Life of Zack and Cody".
And now E! News reports that Cole is coming to the defense
of young actresses who grew up as child stars themselves,
saying that men get applauded for coming out unscathed
from those careers,
but young women are, you know,
tend to be heavily sexualized from an earlier age,
and there's really absolutely no way that he thinks
he and his brother could have survived
if they had comparable experiences.
And Cole says that he will definitely
always defend actresses who had to make it
through the gauntlet of child stardom.
They're here to keep people aware of
how we kind of conduct ourselves in this business
and to be aware moving forward.
Very beautifully said.
Yeah, on a fascinating conversation,
specifically with you, who grew up in the industry,
I mean, you must relate to this.
I don't think I was,
I didn't grow up sexy, you know,
that ended up being an empowered choice on my own
when I was in my late teens.
But it is hard growing up at all,
let alone in front of everybody.
And when you have a job that is required to take
all of your boundaries out of the picture,
that is confusing, at any age.
So I always love when I see men defending women.
Yeah.
I love when I see boys defending girls.
I like that they're asking the industry
to please allow girls to grow up
without capitalizing on their looks.
These are healthy conversations
and in a world of a lot of toxic masculinity,
you have something like this
that is a complete counterbalance to it.
So I appreciated them coming out
and speaking out on behalf of their fellow female coworkers.
I do too.
(audience applauds)
I think it's great. I dunno how you did it.
All right, well, next up, oh, can you believe it, you guys,
it's almost graduation season, right?
Proms.
Hey, prom.
(audience applauds)
Hey graduation.
Oh my God, Ross.
You and I would've been the perfect prom date.
What do you mean "would've been"?
how about could have been?
We should-
What about can't we be?
Why can't we throw a prom here?
If it's good enough for Carrie and Stanford, we can do it.
Let's do a prom.
We should do a prom here.
Would you guys show up?
(audience applauds and cheers)
Yes?
All right.
Well, another thing, it's not just prom season,
It's graduation season.
Yeah, we can go
all the way that night, Rossy.
Yeah, oh, we can?
No.
You're gonna be disappointed at the end of prom,
I'll tell you that.
You're not, you don't like,
I'm not for you.
There is not enough spike in the punch
for that to happen, Drew, at prom.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Well, right here, in New York City, it is graduation time
and NYU has got an epic keynote speaker.
Listen to this.
Oh yeah.
Taylor Swift, everybody, is doing it.
(audience whoops and applauds)
That's crazy.
That is crazy.
Well, Insider reports there's a huge market
for graduation tickets to this.
So Swifties are flooding the internet,
offering to pay students up to $500 a pop
to get into the ceremony.
So this is where, listen.
College students have been going to school for four years.
It's graduation time and they selling their tickets
because Taylor Swift is gonna be there.
And I get it.
Let tell you something.
I feel like I have a PhD in Taylor Swift lyrics, you know?
Absolutely.
But I think about my graduation
and I think it was like,
our keynote speaker was Carl from HR.
You know what I mean?
(audience laughs)
And these kids at NYU get Taylor Swift?
It seems too good to be true.
I did a little research.
It's not the ceremony where you do the cap and gown
and get the diploma.
Oh, what is it?
So, you still could do that.
And I say, if you need a little cash?
Sell.
Do it.
Yeah.
I mean, why not?
Yeah. I,-
It's at Yankee Stadium too, which is so special.
But is she gonna sing
or is she just gonna read a speech?
I would figure that she would be giving a speech.
Okay, but I'd want her to sing. I'd be like, "Sing!".
I know.
I'd be that guy in the back.
You know, I was thinking,
(audience applauds)
you would be a great commencement speaker.
Have you ever done that?
No, but I didn't attend school.
Do you have to have attended school
to give a commencement speech?
No, I just think you have to have
carved an interesting and unique path in the world
that qualifies you to be able to speak on such things.
Hello, am I right?
(audience applauds)
You be fabulous.
I'll do with you.
That was a highlight of my life to hear you say that.
I would be honored.
(bright music)